[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل العربيه كارثه
وفي خبر عاجل منذ قليل
اضربوهم في الليل
والنهار اسد مراسل العربيه ان خمسه
انفجارات
[موسيقى]
اطول هل تسمعين
انا مريضه عملنا في العراق
[موسيقى]
قتل سبعه اشخاص بينهما عدد من العاملين في
قناه العربيه في انفجار سياره مفخخه كل
انسان
العلاقه بلحظه الموت يعرف انه في يوم من
الايام راح يموت
الارباح وتطوير الاعلام العربي الذي هو
اصلاح للعالم العربي
من كان يضم انه بهذا يعبر او يحقق رسالته
فمن الواضح انه مخطئ قوات الام تحاصر
المجمع ويجري التعامل مع المسلحين وفق
مقتضيات الموقع
يقف وراءه وماذا بعد اغتياله لبنانيا
[موسيقى]
حاله الطوارئ وهذا رغم الخطاب بتهدئه تخلى
الرئيس التونسي زين العابدين
اجرموا في حق الشباب المتظاهر
الامن السوري يقتل عشره اشخاص المئات
سقطوا بين قتيل وجريح فعلت مواجهات عنيفه
بالاسلحه الثقيله والدبابات كافه الخيارات
باتت مطروحه في اشاره على ما يبدو للتدخل
العسكري انا دافع ثمان بقائي هنا
اما التقيات اوس
في كل مكان اسعد بان اقدم لكم اول نشره
الاخبار من قناه الحدث تم اقتح
ام ممح لبيان على ما يبدو مقتل صالح تؤكد
ان صالح قتل بالفعل كلاع النظام والاحتفاظ
براس
مليون برميل الاداه الاستثماريه الاهم
للمملكه في المرحله المقبله صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه لدينا اليوم فرص
تكاد تكون خياليه هذه مستويات قياسيه
جديده نراها على سوق الاسهم السعوديه تحدث
عن 50 مليار دولار معظمها منصبه في قطاع
النفط
[موسيقى]
اصلاح المالي الذي
بدا مرات الاجنبيه ما هي مساله بسيطه
فتعيد دراستها وتعيد النظر
يلا يا شباب
برنامج الكاس على العربيه الصخور الخضراء
الى المونديال للمره السادسه في تاريخ
سباقات العالميه للخلود
تقدم مباراه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام تطل عليكم قناه
العربيه اليوم بثوبها الجديد
لتحديث لاخر معلوماتكم لحظه بلحظه تصويت
قد بدات هي تبحث في الواقع الحقيقي في
قناتين
[موسيقى]
رياض ستمثل اضافه كبيره لشبكه العربيه
احدث غرفه الاخبار للشبكه من الرياض
[موسيقى]
عربي مهم جدا
وقناه يتابعونها السعوديين والعرب بشكل
مكثف
ونعتقد انها رسالتنا سوف تصل للسعوديين
والعالم العربي
[موسيقى]